aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'eux
contrôle qualité par apprentissage en
fait je vous parlais de l'industrie
sûr et on va lever pas mal de choses là
vis-à-vis de cette problématique
je termine trois ans de doctorat au
laboratoire sim de l'université de
savoie
je fais juste une série d'un trop sur
qu'est-ce que c'est un doctorat comment
on fait un doctorat en premier il vous
faut un diplôme de master en tout cas en
france mais à l'étranger aussi
ensuite il vous faut des financements
pour pouvoir vous salariés pendant fin
et de salariés pendant trois ans vous
pouvez faire un doctorat pas financer
mais je crois qu'à l'université de
savoie c'est interdit il vous faut des
directeurs de recherche un directeur ou
deux et il vous faut un sujet alors moi
j'ai eu la chance de postuler à
différentes oeuvres de doctorat et moi
j'avais un package tout près le
financement le directeur et donc j'ai
été recruté là dessus et du coup je vous
présenter mon sujet de recherche qui en
fait le ce talk et c'est un problème
industriel
donc on travaille avec des différentes
entreprises
en fait on cherche à réaliser le
contrôle de la qualité des produits
directement sur les lignes de production
donc juste après l'étape qui a fabriqué
le produit on cherche du coup à faire du
contrôle à 100% c'est pas du contrôle en
par prélèvement contient pas prendre 10%
des pièces toutes les heures là vraiment
toutes les pièces vont passer devant le
système de contrôle un truc très
important dans l'industrie on ne veut
pas rallonger le temps de cycle ça veut
dire qu'on veut pas diminuer la cadence
pour faire le contrôle
donc on typiquement moi je travaille en
injection moulage des plastiques les
cadences elles sont voilà maximum c'est
une pièce toutes les 30 secondes donc il
faut un moyen de contrôle qui est en
moins d'une dizaine de secondes et
mesuré discriminer la conformité de la
pièce et qu'on puisse utiliser ça il
faut également un faible coût parce
qu'en fait aujourd'hui les usines il ya
énormément il ya plusieurs machines en
parallèle si vous voulez déployé un
dispositif de contrôle sur chaque
machine bah ça coûte très vite et puis
faut qu'il y ait un retour sur
investissement intéressants pour le pour
les industriels et donc comme j'ai dis
qu'est-ce plastique
il faut également que le système soit
et puis travailler sur différents types
de pièces plastiques donc on peut aller
des par exemple la dimension des pièces
les couleurs les matériaux
voilà donc ça fait pas mal de
contraintes et donc c'était l'objet de
ces trois ans de recherche et donc on
fait de la recherche
en fait la recherche est avant tout des
questions et il y en avait vraiment pas
mal déjà il faut comprendre qu'est ce
que c'est que l'injection des
thermoplastiques
quelles sont les contraintes donc j'ai
parlé du temps de cycle y en a plein
d'autres
on avait qu'est-ce qu'ils vont sortir
chaude de la machine comment on fait
pour mesurer des pièces chaudes
parfois elles sont souples donc à
mesurer si vous venez appuyer dessus
avec un bal peur géométriques
vous déformez la pièce donc vous mesurez
pas la géométrie ensuite qu'est ce que
c'est la qualité d'une pièce donc il ya
des cahiers des charges en géométrie que
ça marche pas mal on peut on connaît
bien on a des cotations géométriques au
hockey par contre par exemple il ya des
défauts type aspects et on avait cahier
des charges spécifique essaye de
spécifier de plus en plus des défauts
d'aspect donc des rayures des démarques
dépollution et ça c'est très dur a
spécifié on s'intéresse à ce qui existe
déjà comme système il ya des systèmes de
contrôle par vision qui existe on a du
scan 3d de ou alors on a aussi un
opérateur qui vient mesurer avec un pied
à coulisse la pièce ça ça existe déjà
peut-être on peut mieux faire enfin
c'était le parti pris du sujet et donc
du coup on a un panel technologique et
ben faut choisir un petit peu arbitres
et quelles technologies on va utiliser
ensuite une fois qu'on a réalisé nos
mesures
donc pendant le temps de cycle en moins
d'une dizaine de secondes et ben faut
réfléchir à comment on va analyser ces
mesures pour à partir des mesures brut
dire si la pièce est bonne ou pas aussi
une contrainte un peu d'utilisation si
on veut que le système soit qu'ils
soient déployés dans les industries et
que les personnes l'utilisent il faut
que ce soit simple à utiliser
simple à installer parce que tout ça ça
coûte ça rajoute au prix et puis enfin
on peut définir en bons ingénieurs un
prix acceptable plutôt du côté
commercial pour que ben pour que avec
toutes ces contraintes ont répondu aux
problèmes
donc en fait des expériences et donc ça
c'est ce que j'ai fait donc là
typiquement on vienne
que là vous avez une presta injecté je
fais pas le détail déjà le préau qui
sait qu'on a un bras robotique qui vient
extraire la pièce de lin de la machine
et donc on peut en faire ce qu'on veut à
près de la classe aujourd'hui les bras
robotique qui sont majoritairement enfin
il existe quasiment sur toutes les
machines d'injection plastique et juste
après la pièce et les prises et elles et
mis lé package et où elle est mis sur
sur un tapis roulant y a pas d'étapes de
mesure à ce stade là donc nous ce que ce
que j'ai mis en place et de la mesure à
partir du avait à l'époque l'aide du
bras robotique voilà ce que ça donne un
peu donc là on avait j'évalue différents
moyens de mesure là on avait une prise
d'image visuel thermique aussi et là
j'avais essayé de faire de maître du
scan 3d donc là vous avez du scan 3d
laser donc on avait on doit faire des
rotations faire tourner la pièce parce
que sinon on peut pas scanner les côtés
voilà suite à toutes ces mesures
donc je crois que deuxième slide pour
vous montrer un peu ce que donc ça on
est plutôt dans la recherche loyer
l'installation c'est c'est pas
automatisés voilà il y avait le pca côté
là on a une image thermique qui vient
d'être prise où il ya la pièce arrive et
les chaudes scan 3d et donc on va voir
le résultat qui s'affiche en live pareil
sur un autre pc voilà la reconstruction
qui s'affiche donc ça marchait pas mal
du tout c'était très encourageant
reste à tous formaliser et surtout reste
à exploiter les mesures voilà les
mesures qu'on peut avoir une image là
visuel de la pièce qui est chaude et
puis un scan 3d de la pièce alors le
scan 3d ça coûte quand même assez cher
et les résultats sont pas terribles
voyez des trous donc on n'a pas vraiment
retenu cette solution
voilà peut-être dans l'avenir il y aura
des scanners de meilleure qualité on
passe à la problématique analyse des
mesures donc là un petit quiz
voilà deux
photos de pièces différentes laquelle
est la petite bonne laquelle à la
mauvaise selon vous à gauche c'est
mauvais ouais oui voilà on voit elle est
pas belle
donc vous êtres humains avec des yeux
vous êtes capable de dire bah ouais
cette pièce là je l'achèterai pas en
fait c'est ça le truc derrière cette
pièce à côté je l'achèterai bon je sais
pas si vous avez besoin de boîte
plastique mais en tout cas si vous en
avez besoin vous préférez celles là
plutôt que celle là est donc la question
c'est comment on automatise ça et
comment on va développer un système
informatique qui va à partir des données
dont des pixels donc une grosse quantité
de pixels plusieurs millions de pixels
dans l'image comment on analyse et
comment on dit si la pièce est bonne ou
pas comme vous le faites humain donc la
proche que j'ai choisie en fait c'est
assez à la mode en ce moment c'est des
réseaux de convolution profond on a
j'ai évalué pas malde approche dans le
cadre de pendant trente trois ans et
finalement ce qui marche le mieux
aujourd'hui c'est ça donc on va utiliser
un réseau donc un algorithme qui est un
algorithme par apprentissage et qui va
être prêt a pris sur plein de plein de
donner complètement différente une tâche
différente en fait la tâche qu'on lui
demande c'est classifie mois 6 millions
d'image dix mois ci par exemple cette
image c'est un chat un chien est ce que
c'est un border collie est ce que c'est
un cocker pas ce qu'il ya dans la base
de données de grosses bases de données
il ya plein des races différentes
d'animaux bref c'est pas du tout utile
mais c'est une base de données très
grosse et on va utiliser un réseau qui a
été appris à faire cette tâche-là est en
lutte si on réalise un transfert de
domaine c'est à dire l'oraison
l'utilisent et on va réapprendre juste
la fin du réseau sur notre problème à
nous qui est est ce que la pièce est
bonne ou pas donc finalement ça marche
très bien
finalement le début du réseau on a
appris des décès un abri d'alive assez
générique pardon de détecter les
contours les contrastes et sur la fin du
réseau c'est plutôt est ce que la pièce
est bonne ou pas ou est ce que c'est un
chat un chien
nous on remplace jusqu'à la fin voilà
pour faire ça donc il nous faut en fait
on a besoin d'humains donc on appelle ça
l'apprentissage superviser parce qu on a
besoin que est un être humain qui nous
disent au début ça c'est une pièce bonne
ça c'est une mauvaise donc on a besoin
de 20 à 40 pièces pour commencer à
pouvoir détecter ensuite la suite si les
questions buzz ou pas donc on a
développé une interface ou à chaque fois
qu'il ya une pièce produite sur la
machine ça s'affiche donc su dans un
navigateur web et l'être humain au début
il peut dire cette pièce est bonne c'est
pièce est mauvaise le système sap après
on continue
et puis quand il ya cette pièce donc au
bout d'une petite demi heure on est
capable de le système devient autonome
donc c'est un transfert de connaissances
soient un peu de résultats pour faire
scientifique
voilà ce qu'on a réussi aujourd'hui donc
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est la
base de données de validation
mais on n'a pas utilisé 18 pièces qui
avaient été mesurés vont les a pas
utilisés pour apprendre notre système
donc ça c'est une base de données de
validation et on voit que le système est
capable de vous dit en fait il est 100%
juste c'est à dire il est capable de
dire ce qui la pièce est bon ou pas à
100%
donc il ya très peu d'erreurs mais
peut-être juste une et en lin et c'est
encore là a priori c'est peut-être en
fait une erreur de l'humain l'humain
s'est peut-être trompé quand il a noté
la base on a d'autres résultats
intéressants en fait c'est on projette
les pièces dans un espace
tridimensionnel à partir de notre réseau
de neurones et là on voit un truc
intéressant c'est que et a finalement
des paquets de pièces conformes les
points rouges c'est des pièces mauvaise
et les points verts des pièces bonne et
finalement aucun on a on a des pièces
mauvaise qui sont similaires par contre
on a différents types de pièces bonne ça
c'est une info qu'on n'a même pas
rentrer dans le système on l'obtient
alors il ya pas mal de limite dans les
systèmes par apprentissage est la
principale limite c'est la limite du
biais du jeu de données de
l'apprentissage qu'est-ce que comment
définir l'objet va par exemple
donc ça c'est une petite anecdote qui a
été qui a été publié dans un papier de
recherche
c'étaient les personnes faisait à peu
près la même chose mais pour détecter
les cancers sur à partir de radiographie
et en fait
donc le principe est le même on a
plusieurs milliers d' radouga de
radiographie on demande aux systèmes
d'apprendre à partir des radiographies
et ben il se met à apprendre avec un
réseau de neurones si la personne un
cancer ou n'a pas de cancer et le
système marche
étonnamment bien il à 100% de bonnes
réponses et en fait a posteriori
quelques années après il ya quelqu'un
qui a repris le l'étude est en fait il
se rend compte que ben toutes les
personnes qui avait le cancer ont été
ont fait leur radio le 20 nov
le 20 novembre toutes les personnes qui
ont pas le cancer elles ont fait leur
radio le 19 elle sauf qu'il ya la date
écrit sur l'image que le système analyse
est donc en fait le système il n'avait
pas du tout appris a analysé la radio il
avait appris à lire les caractères donc
ça c'est le biais et c'est un truc très
très dur quand on bosse avec un système
d'apprentissage typiquement moi sur ma
problématique
ça pourrait être ben voila je produis
des pièces mauvaise et quand je produis
mes pièces mauvaise ben en fait j'ai le
tube néon qui a allumé quand mes pièces
sont mauvaises
et puis je le savais pas je l'ait pas
fait quoi et quand les pièces sont
bonnes j'avais éteint le tube néon et du
coup mon système bas il réagira aux
tubes néons et non pas à la vraie
qualité
donc ça c'est très dur bon c'est un vrai
danger
donc on parle d'intelligence
artificielle notez-le alors il ya des
moyens qui existent pour en fait
analyser si le système s'intéresse
vraiment à quoi ils s'intéressent en
fait pour pour répondre et c'est ce
qu'on appelle en fait des cartes de
sayans donc des algues au développe et
voilà il ya quelques années est en fait
là on a finalement au pont des indes
donc là vous voyez en fait une boîte
mais la valeur de l'influencé de chaque
pixel est pondéré et afficher plus clair
lorsque celui ci a été utilisé par le
réseau pourront fait détecter donc on
voit que là il ya un truc intéressant
c'est que finalement le notre réseau de
neurones ils s'intéressent pas trop au
fond de la boîte ils s'intéressent aux
particuliers au point central et puis
aussi un peu au bord et donc ça ça
voudrait dire ça reste du qualitatif
quand on analyse bien une source le
réseau s'intéresse bien à la pièce et il
s'intéresse pas je sais pas au fond au
fond de l'atelier ou voilà ça ça existe
ça c'est un mettre en place c'est
important alors il ya d'autres limites
plus pragmatique pour plutôt
industrielle et une métrique importante
c'est le taux de faux positifs de votre
système de détection et ça s'est il faut
être particulièrement attentifs à ça
qu'est ce que c'est un faux positif dans
l'autre cas en fait ce serait une pièce
non conforme donc et qui n'est pas bonne
et qui a été classé par notre système
common donc ça veut dire que c'est une
pièce en fait que nos systèmes la pièce
étaient mauvaises au système l'a pas vu
et même pire que pas vu et il a dit que
cette pièce était bonne et ça ça parte
chez le client donc le client il va se
retrouver qu'une pièce mauvaise alors
qu'on lui a certifié qu on contrôler
100% des pièces donc ça on en veut
vraiment pas dans l'industrie en
classique l'industrie dit voilà
aujourd'hui on est à des exigences de
cinq pièces non conformes au milieu des
conforme par millions c'est c'est du
délire c'est énorme et ça c'est ce qui
est demandé par les cahiers des charges
industrielles
nous on en est loin puisque sur nos
systèmes on a 10 % d'erreurs donc 10 %
d'erreurs ça fait dix pièces par me sens
qu'ils sont faux positifs donc on est
mauvais et on n'est pas au niveau requis
pour l'instant pour le pour les cahiers
des charges et du travail à faire sur
l'algorithme hop aussi faire du suivi de
production à partir de nos mesures par
exemple avec suivi multivariée de type
spc ça peut être intéressant
enfin il ya une autre limite à dépasser
vous humain vous êtes capable de prendre
une pièce
et puis de dire ces deux pièces et les
bonnes ou pas en fait vous avez appris
un modèle un peu générique de la qualité
vous savez ce qui est beau vous savez ce
qui est mauvais ça c'est super subjectif
bon alors vous avez peut-être des goûts
différents en musique en peinture mais
en tout cas en pièces plastiques vous
voyez pas là il ya une vraie hurla je
sais que leur valurent c'est pas c'est
pas bien quoi eh bien nous le problème
c'est qu'on a besoin d'apprendre sur
chaque nouvelle pièce mais on peut
imaginer un jour avoir assez de données
pour avoir un système
par exemple si on avait six mille images
par catégories comme dans cette base de
données là et bien peut-être qu'on
serait capable de généraliser à toutes
pièces c'est à dire mon système il
aurait appris un modèle et on lui
présenterait des nouvelles pièces il
détecterait vraiment juste les rayures
plutôt que de dire la pièce non conforme
qui est une région ça permet un deuxième
truc c cole l'humain et ben c'est un
coup de demander à l'humain de dire si
la pièce est bonne ou pas donc on
pourrait réduire le besoin d'avoir cet
humain experts et puis aussi réduire les
biais en fait comme je vous en ai parlé
sur les radios puisque l'humain il est
pas fiable à 100 % même si les experts
et parfois il peut se tromper
en conclusion donc au bout de trois ans
qu'est ce qu'on obtient 1 obtient un
système comme ça donc on a inclus un
éclairage qui s'allument automatiquement
pour maîtriser l'éclairage et voilà donc
là vous voyez le comme tout à l'heure
donc on n'a plus qu'un de 3d on vient
donc toujours le même bras voilà qui est
déjà dans les ateliers on vient prendre
la pièce on vient faire la mesure en
très peu de temps voilà lui mettant ça
prend deux ondes et ça marche pas mal
et puis on a mis ça sous forme d'un joli
design et donc c'est cette chose qui à
côté moi de moi et donc imaginons que je
veuille contrôler une pièce et ben la
pièce elle arrive devant voilà c'est
fait ok donc c'était rapide ça marche
alors ça marche voilà dans avec le taux
d'erreur mais voilà on en est c'est de
l'art voilà il ya pas mal de
développement encore est à suivre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]